welcome back to cbs this morning the
first u.s
approval of a coronavirus vaccine is
potentially just
days away and we're learning about the
challenges
states will face when they roll out
their vaccination programs
after a state receives its allocation of
doses
it must decide how to administer them
and who will be vaccinated
first but as our chief medical
correspondent dr john lepuk shows us
there's concerns some states won't
receive enough
for all of their frontline health
workers
health officials predict that by june
there will be enough covid vaccine to
dose the entire u.s population
but how and when the vaccine gets
distributed will
be a state by state operation that could
start
as early as next week each state is
going to make
their call monsev slowly is chief
advisor to operation warp speed
the group tasked with distributing covet
vaccines to each state
when we spoke with slowing earlier this
week he told us each state will receive
a certain number of vaccine doses based
on population
is there a centralized database where
you're able to follow where things are
when they're there every single vial of
vaccine
will be coded and tracked and we will
understand
where it went when it was manufactured
what was the quality control data of it
who got immunized from that vial when it
is used the data will be entered into
the state system
which then connects into the central
system
also in order to have more security what
we've done is that we have created
a card that's present in each one of the
ancillary bags that go with each dozer
vaccine where there is a syringe and
there is a you know needle and
alcohol and gloves and masks for the
people that are
immunizing pfizer and moderna are
predicted to provide about 40 million
doses by the end of the
year enough for up to 20 million people
this week an advisory committee to the
cdc recommended that the first doses be
given to the approximately 21 million
u.s health care personnel
and 3 million residents of long-term
care facilities
but in some states there may not be
enough supply for example
51 000 doses are required to vaccinate
health care workers in minnesota
but only 19 000 doses are expected to be
available
before the end of the year in california
where portions of the state are in
lockdown due to a surge of new cases
seven hospitals are slated to be among
the first to receive the pfizer vaccine
which requires ultra cold storage
california is expected to receive 327
000 doses by mid-december
with acute care workers in the first
tier dr arthur reingold leads the covet
vaccine work group there
he says vaccine priority will vary from
state to state
if you have a state for example with a
lot of meat packing plants
you may decide that they're really
important place
to vaccinate early other places may
decide that the highest priority should
be people living in nursing homes
while states figure out how to roll out
the vaccine some people still worry
about its safety
the vaccines are being developed in
record time amid a contentious political
landscape
people are understandably asking well
wait a second
the fda has been under such political
pressure
can we trust them this is the highest
standard of scientific evidence two
vaccines from two competing companies
using similar technology but totally
independently developed
ending up having the same vaccine
efficacy the same kind of a performance
provide reassurance enormous reassurance
that these data are real please please
don't let yourself be biased
just open up your mind look at the facts
look at the data and then make up your
mind
an fda advisory committee will review
the pfizer vaccine on december 10th
once that happens the moderna vaccine
will be on deck
expected to be reviewed the following
week
you make such a good point about open up
your mind and look at the facts but it's
very hard to do when you're afraid
and so many people are afraid yeah they
are afraid but
itself to me is more scary yeah i agree
i think it's important to remember we
remember dr fauci earlier made a comment
about the process in the uk what he's
really saying is that here in the u.s
we're actually more meticulous
more careful than they are over there
and that's another reason why look at
the data look at the facts you can trust
this thing
based on what we're seeing so far and
that's a good sign it's a good thing
more careful
yes it's a good thing i i find that
reassuring yeah
john laboum thank you